quinze policiers spécialistes de la
finance chargés de repérer les filières
de l'argent de la drogue en france le
ministre de l'intérieur a également
décidé de renforcer les moyens de
l'office central des stupéfiants
politique la rentrée les ténors jacques
chirac trouve le gouvernement médiocre
mais aussi l'opposition françois léotard
veut prendre la tête du groupe udf à
l'assemblée nationale et georges
marchais est heureux des changements qui
interviennent à l'est
festival du film américain de deauville
deux événements la présentation du
dernier indiana jones et la présence de
lauren bacall la star d'hollywood en
direct dans cette édition
madame monsieur bonsoir on reste
interloqué devant ce qui s'est passé la
nuit dernière au large de mimizan dans
les landes deux gendarmes affectés pour
l'été à la surveillance des plages et un
médecin militaire on en pleine nuit
invité trois jeunes femmes pour un
baptême de l'air entre guillemets qui
s'est malheureusement tragiquement
termine l'appareil s'est abîmé en mer et
les six occupants sont morts
la gendarmerie a aussitôt ouvert une
enquête car évidemment ce vol n'avait
rien d'officiel il était même
parfaitement interdite reportage de
philippe etcheverry stéphane magnier
le pilote avait plus de 20 ans
d'expérience 5000 heures de vol et
pourtant tout le désigne comme le
principal responsable d'une série de
fautes digne d'un débutant en plus de
l'équipage ils avaient embarqué à 2
heures du matin trois jeunes femmes pour
un vol non autorisées l'appareil un
écureuil surchargé et non équipés pour
le vol de nuit voler à très basse
altitude
sans doute pour ne pas être repéré
l'équipage en détachement pour la saison
devait regagner sa base à la fin de la
semaine il avait organisé une petite
fête juste avant le départ
la seule explication que l'on peut
trouver à cette affaire dramatique c'est
que le détachement a beaucoup travaillé
entre juin et septembre dans le cadre
des renforts saisonniers mis en place
pour la surveillance du littoral
beaucoup de nombreuses missions ont été
effectuées 155 au total depuis le début
du détachement secours prévention
assistance aux personnes évacuations
sanitaires et il est évident il est
évident il apparaît clairement que les
gens étaient fatigués à la fin du
détachement et qu'ils ont sans doute
voulu un peu décompressé
toute la journée les hélicoptères et
bateaux de sauvetage ont fait la navette
pour apporter des débris très difficiles
à repérer dans l'eau ou rendu opaque par
le sable et les vagues
pour l'instant trois corps seulement sur
les six victimes ont été retrouvées la
carlingue gît encore par 25 mètres de
fond à un kilomètre à peine de la piste
d'atterrissage
cruelle ironie jusqu'à ce drame la zone
surveillée par l'équipage disparu
n'avait pas connu le moindre accident
fatal de l'été décidé lors du sommet des
pays industrialisés au mois de juillet à
paris la guerre ouverte contre les
trafiquants de drogue se matérialisent
de plusieurs façons attaque frontale
contre les sanctuaires des trafiquants
comme en colombie où comme en france
décision de créer une brigade
spécialisée de policiers formés aux
techniques de la finance pour lutter
contre le blanchiment de l'argent de la
drogue c'est à dire la réinsertion de
cet argent dans les circuits honnête et
classique de l'industrie et du commerce
le ministre de l'intérieur pierre joxe
vient de désigner 15 policiers
spécialement chargé de détecter ces
circuits financiers liés à la drogue et
plus généralement les moyens de l'office
central de répression des stupéfiants
ont été renforcées thierry km
l'office central de répression du trafic
illicite des stupéfiants l'octris double
ses effectifs il passe de 100 à 200
enquêteurs création d'une nouvelle
brigade dans de nouveaux locaux d'une
quinzaine de spécialistes de la finance
de la fiscalité de la comptabilité et de
l'informatique
la france va envoyer des représentants
de la lutte anti-drogue dans les pays
producteurs
c'est la stricte application d'accords
internationaux
enfin les services de police judiciaire
seront renforcés en province cinq cent
quarante policiers spécialisés formeront
leur collègue aux subtilités de la lutte
anti drogue
le tout avant fin 1989 dans le cadre du
renforcement de l'office central qui est
déjà mathon une réalité puisque depuis
cette semaine je bénéficie d'abord aux
40 fchi nouveau et bien les résultats ne
sont pas fait attendre puisque hier soir
un nouveau groupe d'enquêteurs que j'ai
mis en place cette semaine a pu en
flagrant délit arrêter
un réseau complet de six trafiquants
étrangers et saisir 7 kg d'héroïne pure
qui arrivait à paris cette semaine
également à venir nous sommes en pleine
actualité une nouvelle antenne de
l'office central va être installée à
chypre j'ai considéré comme une zone
stratégique comme un des carrefours de
la drogue pour le bassin méditerranéen
c'est à dire que nous entendons que la
police française entend être présente
sur tous les terrains où il se passe
quelque chose en matière de trafic de
super et le cas typique et la livraison
surveillée
c'est une technique de plus en plus
employée par les services spécialisés et
qui demande évidemment une technicité
particulière des moyens importants elle
consiste tout simplement pour 1 ap de
production ou de transit de laisser
partir sous contrôle un lot de
stupéfiants sous le contrôle de nos
agents généralement pour que à l'arrivée
des comités d'accueil entre guillemets
soit organisée et que nous puissions
suivre les filières jusqu'au bout le
plus loin possible
voilà quelque chose de concret c'est de
la coopération pratique alors à quelles
difficultés vont sortez les
gouvernements qui veulent lutter contre
l'invasion de cet argent de la drogue
dans notre société
nous allons devoir tout de suite avec
vous et hervé brusini mais tout d'abord
peut-être une courte experts
explications sur ce terme de blanchiment
de l'argent de la drogue
vous savez daniel que c'est al capone
lui-même qui est à l'origine du mot
blanchiment car l'argent de la
prohibition dans les années 30 il
l'avait investie dans des chaînes de
blanchisserie du linge ma les narco
trafiquants font aujourd'hui à peu près
la même chose avec les milliards de
dollars en liquide qui viennent du
commerce de la drogue pour tout le
problème c'est de donner une
respectabilité à leur fortune alors ils
achètent des immeubles des hôtels des
entreprises de toutes natures et il perd
de l'argent dans des banques créent tout
une multiplicité de sociétés des
sociétés écrans et souvent il respecte
au plus haut point les réglementations
fiscales
même s'ils doivent perdre au passage 40
voire 60 % des sommes de départ car
l'important c'est qu'elle arrive et les
fonds soient sans suspicion possible et
qu'à leur tour ils fassent des petits
qu'il fructifie l'argent de la drogue
est à présent partie prenante de
l'économie mondiale c'est devenu un vrai
problème politique alors détecté
l'argent la drogue ce n'est pas facile
dans
économie libérale comme nous la
connaissons en occident qui va se
renforcer d'ailleurs avec la libre
circulation annoncé pour 1993
c'est vrai qu'il ya là une contradiction
les policiers eux souhaitent un
renforcement des contraintes qui
s'applique aux établissements financiers
pour eux le seul moyen de toucher les
gros bonnets c'est celui là ils veulent
une plus grande transparence sur
l'origine le mouvement l'argent des
règles existent déjà aux états unis en
angleterre en italie
en france pour l'instant on étudie celle
qu'on pourrait mettre en place c'est
d'ailleurs en ce moment même ce que fait
le commissaire vac le patron du nouveau
service de police qui vient d'être créée
mais voilà économie mondiale de ce côté
désire toujours plus de souplesse de
liberté dans la circulation des capitaux
l'europe de 93 vous l'avez dit c'est la
fin des frontières alors à vienne la
semaine prochaine et à paris le 8 sept
ans les experts mondiaux devront
résoudre cette quadrature du cercle
comment dépister l'argent sale sans
entraver le fonctionnement l'économie
économie maintenant encore sous la
présidence française et dans un décor de
rêve l'éden roc au cap d'antibes dans le
sud est de la france réunion ce week-end
des ministres des finances de la
communauté européenne au programme
l'harmonisation fiscale et la monnaie
européenne philippe sassier michel
levasseur
pourquoi ces douze ministres se sont
qu'il réunit au cap d'antibes a déplu
pas si je cite de la côte d'azur dans ce
fameux palace l'éden roc généralement
fréquentée par les vedettes au
portefeuille begag et bien il s'agit
d'une rencontre informelle qui mêle les
séances de travail aux discussions en
tête à tête dans ce lieu de détente
chacun peut se dire ce qu'il a sur le
coeur et à quelques pas de la
méditerranée on teste des compromis qui
concerneront un jour tous les épargnants
et les contribuables européens dossier
numéro un de cette réunion d'antibes
l'union monétaire européenne et
l'harmonisation des fiscalités de
l'epargne entre les différents pays
européens
l'europe devenait commence le 1er
juillet prochain avec la libre
circulation des capitaux
les ministres ont examiné antibes les
moyens de renforcer la cohésion entre
leurs politiques économiques afin de
suivre le même chemin et si possible à
peu près à la même vitesse notamment en
matière de budget de revenus de taux
d'intérêt à antibes les allemands ont
rappelé leur attachement à l'europe
monétaire et les anglais n'ont pas sorti
de contre-projet révolue
pioneer et puis on a beaucoup parlé de
lutte contre la fraude fiscale et de
l'argent sale de la drogue dans une
europe où les capitaux ne connaîtront
plus de frontières projets discutés est
la levée du secret bancaire dans
certains cas sur demande judiciaire
dans les pays où il existe on ne pourra
véritablement juger de ce qui s'est dit
à antibes dont les résultats sont pour
la plupart secret que lors des
prochaines réunions formelles celle-là
des ministres des finances et surtout
lors du conseil européen qui se tiendra
à strasbourg le 5 décembre prochain en
tout cas le chemin qui mène à une
monnaie sinon unique du moins commune à
tous les européens est encore long et le
mistral qui commence à se lever ici ne
semble pas avoir donné aux anglais
l'envi deux mois crée des des pieds la
reprise du travail lundi matin aux
usines peugeot de mulhouse et de sochaux
montbéliard sera un test pour la
direction d'entreprise et des grévistes
la direction qui minimise l'importance
du nombre de ces grévistes
principalement entraîné par la cgt
maryse manon lundi ils ne seront
peut-être plus seul en grève d'ouvriers
peugeot de mulhouse
car dès hier soir le conflit menace est
de gagner les usines de sochaux la plus
importante du groupe
c'est ici dont les ateliers de
carrosserie et peinture qu à l'appel de
la cgt les débrayages ont commencé pour
élargir ce mouvement les syndicats de
mulhouse auront le voyage jusqu'ici dès
lundi journée test du conflit si les
ouvriers travaillent peu le week-end ils
ont quand même deux occasions de faire
parler d'eux aujourd'hui à sochaux le
personnel devait fêter le lancement de
la nouvelle 605 une fête au goût amer
pour peugeot qui fabrique déjà dans
cette usine 120 nouveaux modèles par
jour enfin ce soir le calendrier sportif
opuz les footballeurs de sochaux à ceux
de mulhouse au stade bonal un hasard que
les syndicats comptent bien utiliser
pour mettre en avant leurs
revendications de salaire je blondel le
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
n'aime pas la méthode social de michel
rocard le premier ministre qui selon lui
consiste à abandonner les serviteurs de
l'état c'est-à-dire les fonctionnaires
le règlement des conflits cas par cas ne
solutionne pas définitivement les
problèmes c'est ce qu'il a déclaré
aujourd'hui à lille
par ailleurs monsieur blondel estime que
le pacte de croissance qui lie les
hausses de salaires
au résultat d'économie et dangereux dans
la mesure où en cas de croissance zéro
et bien les salaires n'augmenteront pas
alors que les prix peu le ferons retour
à la normale sur les aéroports parisiens
les pompiers ont terminé leur grève un
accord est intervenu la nuit dernière et
le trafic a repris normalement dès ce
matin rentrait de trois ténors de la
politique française aujourd'hui monsieur
jacques chirac tout d'abord aux
universités du rpr universités d'été du
appert à saint-cyprien dans les
pyrénées-orientales ancien premier
ministre considère que les actions du
gouvernement sont médiocres c'est son
terme
mais il n'est guère plus tendre pour
l'opposition reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
olivier lerner aimé manière non nous ne
sommes pas sur le perron de matignon ou
de l'elysée mais sous le regard attendri
de sa fille et de quelques ex ministre
jacques chirac a vite repris ses bonnes
vieilles habitudes facile mais
réconfortant
les turbulences qui secouent le rpr et
l'opposition toute entière bien sûr on
en parle encore mais philippe seguin est
rentré dans le rang et charles pasqua
est toujours là en garde-fou ne nous y
trompons pas il nous faut inventer le
rassemblement des années 90 et n'ont pas
copié l'udf des années 80 pas de
véritable discours de rentrée pour
jacques chirac à la manière d'un sage
qui voyage beaucoup et qui prend du
recul tel pang l'os il nous a raconté le
monde en 1h30 n'évoquant le rpr que du
bout des lèvres pincées on conteste ce
qu'on a quelque chose à dire
j'ai trouvé qu'au total le débat qui a
eu lieu dans notre mouvement a été digne
fructueux et sympathique est donc
positif et enrichissant l'heure de la
retraite n'a pas sonné pour le président
du rpr qui plus que jamais entente
apparaître en patriarche donc en
président tout court et non loin de
saint cyprien à perpignan très
exactement réunion du parti républicain
de françois léotard qui entend
réaffirmer sa prédominance sur l'udf en
prenant la tête du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale reportage de véronique
santoline et gilbert usant au parti
républicain
ils veulent tous pousser le cochonnet le
plus loin possible depuis hier les
militants les responsables parlent tous
de la même chose
le p r doit faire sa place toute sa
place au soleil de l'opposition les
militants n'ont pas d'état d'âme tout
derrière léotard et tant pis si la
bagarre pour la présidence du groupe udf
à l'assemblée nationale pose problème à
l'oeil
oui alors je vais c'est pas la langue de
bois aujourd'hui le malaise c'est qu'il
ya une élection il ya compétition et
avant compétition mais c'est vrai que
les athlètes se préparent donc là aussi
à une préparation qui se fait mais je
pense que nous avons le meilleur il va
gagner
pourtant quelques mètres plus loin ça
coince charles millon confirme il sera
lui aussi candidat
malgré les conseils or malgré les
pressions et puis il ya les fidèles de
giscard déchiré par le bras de fer qui
oppose le patron de l'udf au patron du p
r
il se donne beaucoup de mal pour sauver
les apparences d'une double loyauté
françois léotard livre aujourd'hui sont
plus rudes combats
fort du soutien d'un parti
inconditionnelle avec le cds à ses côtés
il veut prendre le leadership d'une idf
repeinte par ses soins j'estime
aujourd'hui qu'une position qui est au
parlement copé en trois ans dans le pays
coupé en quatre
ce n'est pas bon et il faut aller bien
au delà il faut probablement faire
effacer les frontières effacer les
frontières de passe de personnes les
frontières du passé les frontières
probablement de structure et allait
aller vers quelque chose qui nous réunit
fille alors je m'emploie ça je suis allé
dire devant le cds vous ne ferez pas
l'opposition sont rpr je dirai demain à
jacques chirac vous ne fait pas
l'opposition son cds il faut tout le
monde pour gagner ce match
demain le parti républicain et le rpr se
retrouveront pour entonner ensemble le
grand air de l'union l'air sera sûrement
le même mais il faudrait attentif aux
variantes et surtout diane écouter tous
les couplets enfin la courneuve dans la
banlieue parisienne traditionnelle fête
de l'humanité l'organe du parti
communiste français le secrétaire
général du pc georges marchais conscient
du trouble jeté pas et les différentes
péripéties que connaissent actuellement
les pays de l'est et l'urss réaffirme la
supériorité du socialisme sur le
capitalisme est il comme montrent
également les événements qui se passe de
l'autre côté du rideau de fer il annonce
qu'il rencontrera dans quinze jours
monsieur gorbatchev à moscou et le
numéro un soviétique justement dans un
discours télévisé cet après-midi a
déclaré que la situation se compliquait
en urss par la faute de certains qui ont
intérêt à répandre l'inquiétude en
parlant de chaos et de risque de guerre
civile monsieur gorbatchev prononcer là
son premier discours de rentrée après un
mois de vacances
les observateurs auront noté son air
grave à la lecture d'un discours
entièrement écrit et le fait qu'il est
annoncé à la fin de son discours des
mesures impopulaires des mesures
exceptionnelles d'assainissement de
l'économie soviétique qui concernerait
avant tout l'approvisionnement et qui
pourrait être donc je voulais dit un peu
plus mais revenons donc à la fête de
l'humanité
reportage de bruno roger petit et
bernard banques
tout bouge to change même au parti
communiste
cette année on disait que la fête de
l'humanité serait semblable aux fêtes
précédentes tradition avant tout
ambiance populaire grand discours
politique le dimanche et point final
mais en l'année du bicentenaire grande
première la fête de l'huma a débuté sous
le signe de la pérestroïka quatre ans
après son lancement et la pérestroïka
est partout jusque sur la grand scène où
se sont épanouis les harmonies subtiles
du hard rock soviétique
quant à georges marchais qui s'est
produit sur une scène un peu plus
étroite à quinze jours d'être enfin reçu
par gorbatchev à moscou il n'a pas
manqué l'occasion de dire tout le bien
qu'il pensait des réformes en sûrs ce
dans tous les domaines
la société connaît un véritable
bouillonnement comme l'a dit récemment à
michael gorbatchev le pays chantent et
nous communistes qui avant tant espérée
ce changement ce n'est pas hélas que
nous avons envie de dire à son propos
fait enfin enfin michael gorbatchev peut
être rassuré son petit frère communiste
français le soutien sans condition le
numéro un soviétique va sans doute se
sentir un peu moins seul ou presque
apport intéressant sur la santé des
français rapport demandé par le ministre
de la santé monsieur claude evin et qui
va sortir lundi prochain déjà quelques
chiffres les maladies cardiovasculaires
sont en régression en france notamment
les infarctus du myocarde
en revanche le nombre des cancers du
poumon dû principalement au tabac est en
augmentation
l'espérance de vie des français a
augmenté de deux années et demie en dix
ans elle est aujourd'hui de 72 ans pour
les hommes et de plus de 81 ans pour les
femmes le nombre des décès par suicide a
fortement augmenté ces dix dernières
années
1261 en 1987 12 1161 en 1987 plus que le
nombre d accidents de la route un peu
moins de dix mille le nombre des
suicides est en augmentation
spectaculaire malheureusement chez les
jeunes de 15 à 24 ans les difficultés
professionnelles et sociales sont à la
base de la majorité des suicides qui
touche plus d'hommes que de femmes trois
fois plus d'hommes que le pas sans
relation de cause à effet bien entendu
les françaises sont plus de 8 millions
chaque année a consulté un voyant ou une
voyante ce week end à paris se tient le
salon de las
ayant justement reportage d'isabelle
steiss et bernard connes comme au
confessionnal les prêtres de la voyance
s'appelle madame de médina la dame en
blanc plus simplement paulette ou simone
ils ont du style de don de double vue
le pendu de monsieur robert nous a
convaincus
la forme est moyenne vous avez dû
certainement vous coucher à cet art moi
je me suis couché de bonne heure
voilà la différence voyez le pendule
tourne beaucoup plus vite s'ils
indiquent qu un magnétisme plus fort
donc une meilleure vitalité pour
reconnaître un voyant honnête d'un
voyant peu honnête c'est facile une fois
d'abord faire attention ne jamais aller
voir un voyante fait trop de publicité
s'il dit qu'il est le meilleur et qu'il
peut tout méfiez-vous 58 le voyais en
france une centaine aux six sélectionnés
pour leur honnêteté et leur compétence
leur ancêtre lisez dans les entrailles
d'animaux eux ont choisi la boule les
cartes ou la voyance pure
puis contre la personne vient devant moi
et bien pour moi il est transparent
je bois et bien les malaises que possède
je vois de ckx fabien exactement
les rois de france avaient leur
astrologues il paraît que presque tous
les hommes politiques ont leurs voyants
ici le client est plus modeste
il vient par curiosité et préfère être
discret et léché species les savoir là
disons si j'allais décembre sur la côte
d'azur
alors c'est quoi votre avenir cosmi vrai
très vieille
90 des cadeaux madame chapelle sera
centenaire monsieur rambert lui a prédit
il ne se trompe jamais la preuve
oui je vois fait daniel bilalian
présentera le journal de 20h ce soir il
a bien dit ce soir il n'a pas parlé de
demain festival les films américains à
deauville deux événements aujourd'hui la
présence de la star américaine
d'hollywood lauren bacall que nous
allons trouver en direct sur les
planches et la présentation du dernier
indiana jones à deauville jean jacques
dufour jean jacques
oui bien je suis là avec lauren bacall
que nous sommes vraiment ravis de
recevoir qui est l'une des stars qui est
venu au festival
vous êtes là vous êtes contente oui en
ce moment on est en plein festival du
film américain est en ce moment sur
invitation il ya la projection d'
indiana jones d'une dernier indiana
jones
on va regarder un extrait parce que je
crois qu'en plus vous l'avez bien aimé
je dois dire que c'est un film
formidable très drôle avec le duo signe
conway et harrison ford ils sont
fabuleux alors un petit extra pour on
revient ici avec madame lauren bacall
google uk
pis
les combats champions
dites-moi est-ce que vous avez aimé ce
film
oui beaucoup je crois que j'aime
beaucoup mais je crois que vous aimez
l'humour et dans ce film il y en a
beaucoup
excusez moi je crois que vous aimez
l'humour et dans ce film il y en a
beaucoup que j'aime bien je ue - ah oui
l'humeur ce qu'ils aiment moi à oui oui
j'aime toujours ça madame et j'ai vu
tout à l'heure pendant la conférence de
presse que on vous demander ce que vous
pensiez des hommes vous disiez que vous
les aimiez bien en général mais que
malheureusement ils étaient tous mariés
oui c'est l'avé maria rien à faire
madame dans l'os d'apple dans la
conférence de presse une sorte d'appel
vous réclamiez quelque chose non non bon
ben daniels vous vouliez poser une
question à lorraine bon alors la
présentation je conseille encore quelque
chose en jalles présentateurs on n'a
rien oui abandonné par vous avez fait
beaucoup de films le port de l'angoissé
key largo on les a cité un certain
nombre
le premier celui de warhawk c' est ce
que c'est votre film favori le port de
l'angoissé langage langlois c'est la map
j'aime ça beaucoup pour habiller suis
pas ce que c'est c'est mon premier film
mais c'est avec offrir au barça et tout
le monde s'émerveille à moi c'est
formidable
vous avez arrêté le théâtre il ya deux
ans pourquoi il stoppe ceci entre ríos à
oui parce que oui parce que je veux
tourner les films encore jeu j'ai arrêté
depuis sept ans c'est trop longtemps et
j'aime le film beaucoup et je veux
commence en cra je changer la vie un
petit peu je le dis à votre place de ce
que vous l'avez dit vous-même tout à
l'heure lauren bacall je crois lance un
appel aux producteurs français au
réalisateur elle adorerait tourner en
france
oui je veux mais j'attends
non écoutez donc si vous nous entendez
voilà l'appel est lancé qu'est ce que
vous comptez faire après le festival du
film de deauville
je vais à paris voilà je vais les choses
j'ai les choses à faire j'ai justement
fini un film à en californie si c'est un
peu vacances est un pur business
je crois savoir que vous êtes démocrates
et que vous disiez tout à l'heure
quelque chose d'assez amusant entre les
républicains et les démocrates à propos
des idées justement à propos croire des
idées idea to you see you speak about ce
démocrates et républicains expliquent
les difficultés et des as one who have a
nice c'est pas difficile à voir l'idée
c'est c'est toujours difficile à voir
opinion parce que je ne sais pas le mot
en français mais c'est sérieux voire
plus facile si on dit quelque chose si
vous êtes par lequel ils ont va on va
lauren bacall gens jaloux on va vous
laisser discuter politique parce que
malheureusement je n'aurais pas pu poser
parce qu'elle ne m'entendais pas une
question à lauren bacall ce sera pour
une prochaine fois
et on va passer aux sports situation
délicate pour le pilote français alain
prost engagé la saison prochaine par
ferrari il a été accueilli avec ferveur
par les supporters italiens sur le
circuit de monza où tu vas courir demain
mais il est en difficulté au sein de son
écurie mclaren qui a du mal à accepter
ce départ et prost sous sol même ses
employeurs de vouloir l'empêcher de
gagner sur la ligne de départ demain
il partira en quatrième position
derrière senna et les deux ferrari
justement de mansell et bergues heures
sur place nos envoyés spéciaux
lionel chamoulaud toxiques à alain prost
à l'asthme ou délits à l'an prochain les
tifosi
bill oui mais voilà en attendant cette
année encore chez mclaren
prost ne rigole pas les raisons de la
colère une mclaren complètement largué
totalement déréglée à monza c'est jamais
la même voiture lada provocation de
tours de préparation 2
la tension sur le même problème mais là
bien entendu les amplifier donc une
seconde 8 d'écart alors je fais même pas
le temps que je faisais en essais privés
il ya un mois et demi si avec des plats
de course incroyable une seconde 8 de
retard au tour sur à ayrton senna si ce
n'est pas de la magouille cela y
ressemble d'autant que les doutes ne
date pas d'hier
et comme depuis avant-hier prost a opté
pour ferrari un second choix va
peut-être s'imposer alors prost au micro
lionel chamoulaud comme ça j'attends les
courses 2 puis on verra bien après le
point presse allemande envisage
éventuellement d'arrêter en cours de
saison de conduire aux mclaren honnête
c'est dur c'est des questions très
difficiles juste à chaud après la
prédation
mais avant un éventuel salut de
l'artiste l'actualité c'est la grille de
départ de ce grand prix d'italie à
ayrton senna en pole position
c'est la neuvième de la saison derrière
mansell et bergues heures sur ferrari
ensuite seulement on retrouve alain
prost est derrière prost les habituels
williams-renault de pas très et bout de
scène
départ cet après-midi du bol d'or
motocycliste sur le circuit du castellet
le point tout de suite avec claude et
marc les pilotes d'un côté les machines
de l'autre le départ du bol d'or c'est
toujours impressionnant
soixante et onze équipages engagés pour
cette 53e édition est tout de suite ce
sont les deux favoris qui se porte en
tête merkel duhamel merten sur la honda
rouge numéro 2 et vieira mattioli
burnett sur l'autre honda numéro quatre
et deux motos d'usiné ont réussi les
meilleurs temps en essais vieira
obtenant la pole position en deux
minutes 2 secondes 77 centièmes sur les
5 km 800 du circuit mais première
surprise dès le second tour
hervé moineau le champion du monde en
titre parvient avec sa suzuki bleus à
tenir tête aux deux honda mais trois
tours seulement puisque merkel élira
reprennent le commandement dès le
cinquième tour
on le voit le bol d'or a démarré très
vite cette année
mais attention les machines devront
tenir 24 heures puisque l'arrivée sera
jugée demain à 15 heures à l'instant
même aux internationaux des états-unis
qualification pour la finale de
l'allemand de l'ouest boris becker qui a
battu en demi finale donc que
l'américain chris stein en trois sets il
rencontrera en finale soit agassi soit
lendl qui vont jouer leur demi finale
championnats du monde de natation
synchronisée à la piscine des tourelles
apparaît victoire par équipe des
américaines l'équipe de france a été
malheureusement distance et claude
heymann elles ont le sourire les
nageuses américaines elles savent
qu'elles ont réussi un superbe ballet
d'ailleurs les notes confirment elles
sont champions du monde de nage par
équipes
c'était aujourd'hui la troisième et
dernière épreuve de ces championnats du
monde que les américaines ont
littéralement dominé puisqu'elles se
sont imposés en solo en duo et donc par
équipes grâce à un programme tout à fait
originale
classement général final première les
américaines donc deuxièmes les
canadiennes troisième les japonaises qui
réussissent là une performance
inattendue 4e les soviétiques et 5e les
françaises que nous voyons actuellement
et françaises qui avaient pourtant battu
ces mêmes soviétique il ya un mois à
bonn pour les championnats d'europe ce
qui leur avait permis de s'élever sur la
plus haute marche du podium
synchronisez aussi l'arrivée du tiercé
du quarté + cet après midi pour gagner
il fallait jouer le 13 le 11 et le neuf
ça rapporte un peu plus de 13 mille
francs pour ce qui concerne le quarté
ajouté le 2 et vous gagnez plus de cent
mille francs cent dix neuf mille francs
les pronostics pour demain toujours les
pronostics 2-2 pierrette brès pour le
prix comparex à longchamp je vous laisse
le temps de noter les favoris de
pierrette le 6 le 12 le 7 le neuf le 4
le 8 places et le 2 voilà ce journal est
terminée tout de suite après les
prévisions météo avec josé dans la
pierre aux alentours de 22 heures 40
philippe gassot pour le tout dernier
journal de ce samedi quant à nous si
vous le voulez bien nous retrouvons
demain à 13 rebonds soir